nato what role now for the alliance
in the interview nato general hans
lauter dombrowser
as head of the nato headquarters in
bronson you're responsible for
afghanistan
after 13 years the nato combat mission
there ends in a few weeks time how
stable is the country
i am responsible but of course the
responsibility is spread over many
shoulders we're doing it together the
commander in kabul plays a very
important role we set ourselves the task
firstly of ensuring that there are no
more terror camps
secondly of building up security forces
that can ensure stability
we've achieved that
we've built up a 350 000 strong security
force financially but we also train them
they're very efficient and they're
accepted by the populace and they can
safeguard law and order so we can in all
conscience end the combat mission on
schedule we've made a lot of progress
from the health system to trade it's all
running very well
the second important thing which the
afghans themselves have created is the
political transition the first
democratic handover of power president
karzai governed for almost 12 years his
time is over a new president has been
elected dr ghani a very experienced man
who has formed a coalition government
with dr abdullah
and they are now starting their work it
took them some time after the elections
on april 5th
it was but we know from other countries
belgium for instance that forming a
government can take a bit longer that's
not a big criticism
now the government is there and the key
thing is that the president to sign the
nato sofa as we call it the status of
forces agreement we can stay on we have
the legal foundations for a new mission
train assist advise training only no
combat deployment no longer on the
streets only in academies and barracks
in ministries
this new mission is called resolute
support can you explain what's behind
that name what exactly will the new
mission do
it will be a trinity training that means
we need to teach the highest leadership
how to carry out combined and joined
operations
so the fight against insurgency against
pockets of resistance
we also need to teach them they can do
it already but we need to refine it air
land integration so how do you use
helicopters and land forces to best
affect
and we need to teach them about defense
procurement even in germany that's a
difficult topic
it's a long-term project we need to keep
doing all that and we plan to keep doing
it
this mission will also be present in
other major cities not only kabul
in afghanistan
correct will there be combat troops too
yes combat troops are part of it because
i have to make sure that our 12 000
soldiers who will be stationed in masari
sharif in herat in kandahar in baglan
and kabul are always protected
we still cannot rule out that there are
people who are not friendly towards us
and who could open fire
we recently had a painful experience in
the kabul academy so that a so-called
insider and afghan turned around and
shot dead my friend the american general
harold greene
the german general michelle bancho was
seriously wounded we have to protect
ourselves against that that's one
example where it didn't work and we have
to be on our guard
attacks inside attacks you mentioned
earlier pockets of resistance how come
the taliban has not yet been defeated
well is there even a short answer
i can't explain it conclusively i can
only say we can see that everywhere
where we have stable governments the
chance that pockets of resistance
disappear is much greater
we have an unstable situation
in parts of afghanistan we still have
social injustice and in the border area
with pakistan especially there are some
20 million people living in the utmost
poverty on both sides of the border and
those areas are the breeding ground for
terrorism unfortunately that will always
be the case we cannot rule it out but i
want to say quite clearly every death is
one too many but we're happy that
statistically the numbers are going down
and we're on a good path
what's the most important lesson for you
from the afghan deployment
not just afghanistan but also kosovo in
bosnia where i also served have each
demonstrated three things
as have libya and iraq as negative
examples if we embark on a mission we
want to win the peace in kosovo and in
bosnia we succeeded and we can only win
the peace of the military politicians
and the business sector work together
the coalition that we formed with around
50 nations in afghanistan has been
effective
we built up the security forces together
we can strike defend fight that's not
the problem you can only use that to
keep an opponent at bay but you haven't
built up a secure civil society you need
political stability that's up to the
government itself that's not our task
and you need a justice system and
economic system all that has to grow and
only if those three things come together
is there the possibility of winning the
piece if the military goes in alone and
the two other factors are missing you
could stay there for a lifetime without
success
many in nato are saying the time of big
foreign deployments is over
now we really need to urgently focus on
the core task
did nato because of the foreign missions
neglect the defense of the alliance drop
the ball on national defense
the strategic concept contains three
tasks the first and most prominent is
collective defense that was decided in
2010 and it hasn't been forgotten
was it implemented in practice every day
not always
yes we held major exercises but i will
say that of course we have had a bit of
an eye-opener and that was the illegal
seizure of crimea
no one saw that coming
we were making good progress with russia
and many other partners in building up
security and stability that went well
for 25 years we're just about to
celebrate 25 years of the fall of the
berlin wall hungary is free poland is
free the baltic states are free it all
worked out well and we thought it would
continue with russia we wanted that
until we had this eye-opener
and now there are some especially those
who live near russia especially the
baltic states the poles who say hold on
we need to do more for our national
defense than for foreign
defense in crimea in eastern ukraine
russia has demonstrated a completely new
type of warfare an unconventional type
of warfare how can nato as a
quasi-classical defense alliance equip
itself to deal with the so-called little
green men combatants without national
insignia
warfare has always been about being
smarter than your possible enemy using
clever tactics but you know that in nato
we're all bound by the rule of law we
can't just show up in some market square
in jeans or wander across the borders
and gather intelligence or poke around
we don't do that nato is a defense
alliance so the question is if the
famous green men come we have to
identify them i believe that that is
initially not a military task but a
government task perhaps domestic
intelligence the secret services
domestic security
institute
to react to this new threat scenario
from eastern europe nato decided at its
summit in wales to set up a rapid
reaction force a so-called spearhead
unit
have you started already
how far along is the work
yes of course we've started the nato
resolutions in wales on september 5th
were implemented the next day at least
in theory
between the decision by the heads of
state and the reality on the ground we
have undertaken to achieve that within
one year that is very very ambitious
such projects take longer
we need a stable troop force brigade
size perhaps 5000 strong with what we
call force enablers reinforcements
intelligence infantry whatever they need
special forces medics they need all of
that too
we have all of that it just has to be
sorted and knocked into shape
the key thing about this force is that
we need to be able to deploy it fast
for that you need aircraft and that's
not always easy you need strategic
airlift that exists you can rent it so
long as there's peace
the americans have it and we're getting
it with the a400m
germany will have modern equipment
someday soon so it will be possible
what's also new is a more intensive
training cycle so that the troops can
really deliver and we can say yes we can
protect people that's our main task
is nato returning to a strategy of
deterrence against russia
i don't know the nato strategy was
always based on deterrence i've always
said anyone who attacks nato territory
they're not dealing with just one
country but with all 28
and probably also with friendly partners
but certainly with more than one country
nato has its article five its defense
solidarity clause i think that's beyond
dispute and i don't think that president
punti would march into tallinn with
tanks because he knows he would
immediately face an incalculable risk
reaction force needs air transport
that's a major problem in nato in
germany there's a vigorous debate going
on about equipment shortages in the
military a lack of air transport
helicopters that don't function properly
is that also an issue with your fellow
nato officers the shortfall in german
defense procurement
no to be honest in nato we say
regardless of rank or uniform we don't
talk about nations we talk about
capabilities the capabilities that have
been provided to me for a mission
take the example of afghanistan
what's going on at home is not an issue
of course as an interested citizen i
read about it but i judge it by the
missions in afghanistan the tranzals are
flying very reliably to everyone's
benefit in afghanistan the helicopters
are flying and of course you should
never ask a general if he'd like more
equipment
yes i could use more but i can fulfill
my mission i have a multi-national force
and everyone has to contribute and
germany is certainly making its proper
contribution in afghanistan
that we would like to have the a400m
that's a private opinion just like a car
you'd like to have a new one but in
afghanistan the transals and the
helicopters are in the air
within the nato alliance are there
similar discussions to here in germany
yes that's not just a german issue we
nato soldiers are always talking about
capabilities about what we need
you could also just as easily say i can
only gather intelligence if i have
satellites not every state has
satellites
each has to make its own contribution
and germany is making its contribution
including training currently with the
kurds in iraq
germany is doing its bit german patriot
anti-missile batteries have been
stationed in turkey for years we are a
major deployment force in kosovo so i
think in comparison to the nations under
my command germany is the second largest
that's not nothing that's a lot
head of allied joint force command thank
you very much for your answers
thank you